louis de funès réussite actuellement un
étonnant doublé à la comédie des champs
elysées d'abord il joue la valse des
toréadors une pièce de jean anouilh
donne une bonne dose de garder nos
ennuis ce n'est qu'elles finiront par se
réveiller on est de chicala deux
extraordinaires eu une heure non plus
rien je n'arrivais presque à revenir
quelques idées mon cher la médecine
devrait trouver un moyen pour faire
dormir éternellement les femmes
voulaient réveillerez un petit moment là
yeux une sampdoria général si c'était
possible
quel est votre personnage dans la
vanille toréador c'est le rôle d'agent
général
vous savez moi je ne raconte pas
bienvenue à contenu que moi c'est le
rôle d'un général qui a un grand amour
de sa vie qui est mademoiselle de
saint-omer
l'étrange enchantement de cette première
20 fax des toréadors à la la la la la la
la la la
mademoiselle voulez vous m'accordez cet
axe vous restez amoureux béatrice votre
amour votre infidèle oui bien sûr les
aujourd'hui il est toujours fidèle à ma
faim jusqu'à mon manager pour boire
quand tu l'assumés et la générale
comment réagit-elle oui on a maquillé le
quatrième à tout ça barde [ __ ] madame
les jeunes chiens vieillissant va tant
que huit dents il est autoritaire toute
manière est autoritaire puis moi je ne
peux pas faire de rejoindre mon choix
mon vrai métier était le théâtre avant
je vais par le théâtre et le cinéma
mais c'est là qu'il ya le plus c'est là
que quel public c'est là qu'on joue avec
le public c'est le plus difficile depuis
physique le cinéma le cinéma ya des
journées qui sont durs très durs mais ça
n'est pas difficile encore commencé au 4
6 l les parisiens de paris de passage
s'ouvrir aux aventures du général saper
toute la france en revanche peut rire
aux aventures de rabbi jacob
le dernier film de gérard oury c'est
très intéressante se servir du véhicule
comique et c'est principalement là que
ma collaboration très intime avec louis
de funès et fructueuse
c'est que louis de funès et un un
extraordinaire interprète comique c'est
à dire que c'est peut-être le seul
acteur au monde qui ait la possibilité
d'être odieux sans être antipathique
au papier tout de suite mon personnage
c'est monsieur pivert personnage tient
dans tejari il sa fille c'est danièle
thompson c'est un bonhomme en quittant
comme l'oiseau il est en kit ou france
un petit voiture qui souhait
et puis après anti-juifs anti-arabes il
est en kino hayatou il en titre et
contre tous les belges eux c'est peut
pas les voir les bugs n'importe quoi
je ne serai pas chez vous vous monsieur
le rabbin
notre propos n'est pas de funès et moi
de faire la politique c'est pas ça
monsieur ne l'ait pas dit qu'il
m'inspire était juif parce qu'il ya je
ne l'étais pas voilà sont pas des gens
qui véhicules lourds eux qui en voyant
des messages néanmoins il ya derrière
les gags derrière l'humour derrière le
comique fantastique de louis il ya
quelque chose qui je l'espère va passer
à cet égard qui touchera peut-être lé
coeur des hommes
moi aussi je marine arrive c'est pas ma
fille de mariani noir
et moi j'ai commencé il m'arriva tas de
choses il apprécie finalement j'avais je
suis beaucoup moins intolérant à la fin
du film et ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien
moi parce que le peuple qu'on fait c'est
ma part j'avais des bonnes petites idées
aussi en tire il doit me rester encore
mais ça m'a comme je dirais gérard isama
décrasser l'âme
nokia va